[音楽]
[拍手]
はい皆さんこんにちは
株式会社リスナーホールディングス
の吉本と申しますよろしくお願いします僕
は仕事の中でsdgsの啓発活動に
取り組んでいますこれまで当社グループの
従業員そしてお客様に向けてsdgsに
取り組むことの大切さをお伝えして
意識を変え行動を起こしてもらうことに
取り組んできましたでも今日僕は皆さんに
社会を良くするためにsdgsをやり
ましょうというつもりないんですなぜなら
それでは人の意識はなかなか変わらないし
行動も起こしてもらえないそういうふうに
思ってるからです
確かにここ数年で日本の中でsdgsの
認知とずいぶん高くなりました皆さんも
このカラフルなロゴマーク目にする機会が
増えてきたと思いますそれに合わせて
sdgsに対する理解も広がってきました
sdgsとは
恵まれない人々や
絶滅しかかっている生き物たちに
救いの手を差し伸べましょうということ
だけではありません
むしろお金さえ払えば電気やガスをいつで
もスイッチ一つで自由に使うことができ
たり
安全な飲み水や食料をちょっとコンビニに
行けばいつでも簡単に手に入れることが
できたりこういう今の日本の社会の
当たり前がこの先もう通用しなくなるかも
しれない他人事ではなくて自分を落として
取り組んでいかないといけないことなんだ
こういう理解もだんだんと広がってきてい
ますでもそれでもまだ行動を起こしてい
ない人の数が少なくありませんそうした人
たちに自分ごととして捉えてもらって行動
を起こしてもらうことこれは本当に難しい
ことなのです
ところがですねこの大変難しいことを僕は
仕事としてやることになりました今を遡る
ことを約2年前
りそなグループの
推進の責任者をやってほしいという事例
この事例を僕はうちの社長から直接
受け取ったんですその時社長にはこう言わ
れました
君にはねイソナグループ3万人の従業員の
意識行動改革の
リーダーをやってもらいたい正直に言い
ますねこの時に頭真っ白だったんです
だってね6時3人家族なんですけど家庭の
中でも大したリーダーシップがはっきりし
ないんですよそれがねいきなり3万人
びっくりしましたさらに社長にこう言われ
た
[音楽]
明日から本気出します
多分心の中で今日は無理って思ったん
でしょうね1万倍ですからそんなことが
あってから2年間
社内の意識行動改革そしてお客様の啓発
活動に取り組むことになりましたところが
これがもう苦労とさせその連続だったん
ですそもそも僕ですね
人とお話する人前で話すめちゃくちゃ苦手
です
喋ってますけど喋りながらね
銀行員生活25年になりますが営業やって
もたった4ヶ月人の心を動かすトーク
なんてやってきてないんですよそれでも
3万人伸びたとして
社内研修一生懸命やりましたコロナで集合
研修を難しかった時期は
社員の方が好きな時に見てもらえるような
研修とか一生懸命作りました自分で自由を
作って説明原稿を自分で書いてカメラを
分かって自分で撮影してあげよう動画の
編集も自分でやりましたね家族から
お父さんはYouTuberの転職願っ
てるんじゃないかもかけられるぐらい
頑張りました時にはお客様のところに行っ
て企業の経営者の方と直接お話もさせて
もらいましたその結果ほとんど響かない
ですまあ僕ごときのトークで響くのはもう
意識変わっているか変わりかけてる人まで
大抵の人のところなんですよいや確かに
大事なことだと思うよでもねなんか世の中
よりもねなんかねで胸がついちゃうんです
ね中にはねいや今日はねとってもために
なる話聞かせてもらって勉強なんて
ありがとうじゃあこれからも頑張ってね
いや僕ねあなたに頑張って欲しいと思って
今日はお会いしに来たんですよなんてこと
言えるわけないですね
そんなことが1年ぐらい続きましてこれ
やっぱりどこには無理なんじゃないか心が
折れそうなってる時ある人からこういう
こと言われたんです
人間はね
価値を感じたことは自ら進んで行動する
よ君のミッションはsggsに取り組む
ことにどう価値をつけてそれを相手にどう
感じさせるかなんじゃないのハッとしまし
たね確かに僕社会良くするために誠実
頑張りましょうそんなことばっかり一生
懸命喋ってて相手に価値を感じさせ
るってちゃんと考えてなかったんじゃない
かなでもそれどうやったらできるんだろう
か
わからないまままたある時取引先の経営者
さんとお会いすることになりましたいつも
通りお話していつも通り響きませんでした
むしろその方sdgsについて
背景や歴史も含めてとっても保存性その上
で今の日本の社会のsdgsの風潮に対し
て
否定的な方だったんですその方の会社は
100年以上続く会社です100円という
ことは
太平洋戦争を経験してるんですね実際に
社会価値を崩壊しました公共インフラ
サプライチェーンになりましたそんな中で
も自分の会社の授業とそこで働く十分の
方々の雇用と生活そして日本の復興を支え
続けてきたそんな一族の方だったんです
そんな方にしてみたら何をやったことも
ない人間が
持続可能な社会づくり持続可能な
体しく言ってくれない直接そう言われた
わけじゃないんですけど僕ねそういう
雰囲気をビシビシ感じちゃいましてそこで
話すと諦めました逆にねもらった時間余っ
ちゃったんですよこれなんか話すことない
かなと思って話し始めたのが上智大学の
学生さんの話だったんです僕去年があれば
この大学でsdgsの寄附
いろんな仕事をしたいとかものすごく関心
高いですこんなデータがあります
去年
りそなグループの取引先約3万1000社
からsdgsのアンケートその結果大企業
の市場の結果代これはsdgs
一方で
圧倒的多数を占める中堅中小企業の市場の
経営課題これは人材の確保と育成だったん
ですこれ大企業でも5番目の経営からに
断定してますほとんどの企業が人材確保
経営開発と認識するんですその背景にある
のは日本の少子高齢化ですこの先さらに
人口が減っていくと働く世代の数も入って
いきますもしこの先自分の会社に人が来て
くれなくなったらいずれ業務やる人いなく
なって会社維持できないです
この先大企業というのも人材確保に苦労
すると言われてますましてや今やsdgs
は学校教育に正式に組み込まれましたこれ
から社会に出てくる学生の方々今の社会人
よりも時間をかけてSGの勉強してます
仕事選びにもその観点が入ってくる可能性
否定できませんそして実際にそういう学生
さんはすでに出始めてるんですはい
そんなこんなでその方と
急に話が叶えるようになります最後は
りそなグループがご提供しているsdgs
のコンサルティングについて一度話を聞か
せてくれないここまで行きましたSJ実践
に取り込むことに価値を感じなかった人が
これから先も自分の会社に人が来て
もらえるようにしていくにはsdgs本気
で取り組まないといけないんじゃないか
そこに価値を感じてくれたんです
この価値を感じさせるのは僕ではありませ
ん上智大学の学生さんですと本当に
ありがとうございますでもねその学生さん
たちもまさか僕とね雑談レベルで話した
頼らないことがまさか企業の経営者の意識
や行動を変えるなんて
夢にも持てなかったと思います
はい今のこの経営者の方の感謝って6年
学生さんについても同じようなことがいる
んじゃないかなと思うんですどういうこと
かというと学生さんの中には
興味関心ないしキラキラ系のインスタで
入ってるファッションでしょそう思ってる
人がいたとしても僕ね全然不思議と思って
ないですでもそんな人でもこう言われたら
どうでしょうか
就職をするんだったら
将来性のある会社を選びたくないですか
どうせなら社員を大事にしてくれるあなた
の考えを尊重してくれる会社に入りたく
ないですか
僕金融機関に長いこと勤めてそこを
見定める簡単な方法そのやり方を3分で
説明できるんだけどちょっと話聞いてみ
ませんかどうですかこう言われたら
就職活動の方に3分ぐらいちょっと話して
もいいかなと思いませんか今日の学生の
方々この場にいらっしゃるんですけどどう
ですかね話聞いてあげてもいいかなと思っ
てもらえますか
ありがとうございますここからですね
esg目線という話させてもらいますこの
イギリス人目線というのは企業のsdgs
の取り組みについて
Eは
環境Sが社会Gはガバナンスこの3つの
目線から確認することでその企業の将来性
を評価する方法ですこれ実は世界のプロの
機関投資家が
投資先の企業の将来性を評価するに使って
ますプロの方と同じことするのはさすがに
大変なんで今日はするぎゅっと圧縮して
くるこれから3分間でそのやり方説明し
ます聞いてくださいまず環境からいきませ
ん
注目してもらうのはその企業が自分の
ところが出して二酸化炭素にカーボン
ニュートラル目標を設定しているかです今
や世界の国々がカーボンニュートに向けて
動き始めました日本政府の2050年
カーボル宣言証明してます事業活動を続け
て限りこれらと無関係で位置づけることを
まず不可能ですはいそんな中で一つ目の
会社まだ自分の会社のカーボン
ニュートラルの曲を出してない2つ目の
会社カーボンに当たる目標を出してますで
も中身を見ると世界の目標日本の目標より
も
低い目標になってます必要な会社世界の
今日日本の目標と同じかそれよりも高い
目標を出してますはい10年後
業界の中で最も優位に立場に立ってる可能
性高いのは3つのうちどこだと思います
これご飯の皆さんにお別れします次社会
ありますよ
注目してもらうのは人材の多様性いわゆる
ダイバーシの取り組みですこの先大企業と
いっても人材確保に苦労すると言われて
ますそんな中で
男性であろうが女性であるが新卒採用の方
であるが中卒さえなかったやろうが国籍も
経歴も関係なくどんな人に入ってきて
もらっても誰もが活躍できるようにして
いくために明確でそして
納得感のある目標を掲げてその目標に向け
た取り組みの実績も
詳しく情報公開を始めている企業とまだ
そこまで始めていない企業はい10年後
どちらの会社に人はより多く残っていると
思います
最後ガバナンスできませんガバナンスの
言葉の意味は知らなくても大丈夫です
注目してもらうのは取締役会これは
企業の中で最も重要な経営課題について
経営陣が議論する会見のものですポイント
を3つ申し上げます1つ目のポイント
取締役会のメンバーがほぼほぼ社内の人
だけ
社長の側近だけで固められている企業会社
の外からも様々な分野の専門家を呼び集め
て経営陣と対等な立場で自由闊達な
ディスカッションを始めている企業
将来の成長力に期待が持てるのはどちらの
会社ですか
2つ目のポイント取締役会のメンバーの
会議への出席率が高い企業と低い企業
重要な経営課題についてよりしっかりした
ディスカッションができてそうだと思えれ
ばどっちですか
3つ目のポイントこうした取締役会の活動
状況について
詳しく情報を公開している企業とそんなに
主に出せない
けどどっちの会社の経営の方に安心感を
感じます
esg目線これだけですこのぐらい見て
おくだけでもその企業の将来性について
自分なりの判断目線が回るような気がし
ませんかこうした情報は上場企業であれば
ホームページまたはディスクロージャして
見つけることができますこれよかったら
是非一度試してみてくださいもしかすると
皆さんが自分の将来のことを考えて取る
その行動が
企業の経営者の意識行動を変えるかもしれ
ません実例は先ほどお話したそうです
じゃあ続いてesgmちょっと違う話させ
てもらいますね
将来性もあって
従業員を大切にしてくれる会社に実際に
入ってその後どうでしょうかどうせなら
そこで
活躍できる人材になっていきたいつまり
自分の人材価値市場価値を高めていきたい
と思いません
これからの時代企業が求める人材の一つ
それが
持続可能な収益を作り出せる人材ですこれ
ができる人はどんな企業どんな業界に
飛び込んでいってもまず活躍できます何
だったら自分で事業を立ち上げてもらって
もいいと思います
そのヒントはsdgs
は世界共通の困りごとですソリューション
に対する世界規模なんですもしこれを
ビジネスかつまり収益化することができれ
ば
持続可能な収益につながってきます
どうですか今からねsdgsとビジネスの
関係についてちょっと親調べを始めておい
ても
将来損にはならないと思いませんもちろん
社会に出てそういう仕事に関わってから
勉強することできます実際今の社会人は
そうしてますでもどうせなら早く始める
ことを僕はお勧めしますなぜならビジネス
の世界何のかの時間処分のところ大きい
からです
はいそろそろねお時間が迫ってきちゃった
ので話変えますねそもそも人見知りで人前
で話すの苦手なはずの僕が何で今日こんな
場所に出ようと思ったかそれについて話し
てください
所詮僕一人の力なんかで世界を変える
なんて出来やしますでももし今日僕の話を
聞いて一人でもsdgsに来て興味に関心
を深めてもらおう何か行動を起こすことに
価値を感じてくれたら僕の力は結果的に2
倍になるんです
社会6章なんて思わなくていいんです自分
の将来していくために今世界が向かおうと
しているSGSこの大きな流れに目を向け
てくれたらそれでいいんですそんな人が
何にもで作れたら僕の力を何回も広がって
いきます
それが人見知りで無力なここにできる世界
を変えていく調整の大規模なんじゃないか
そこに価値を感じて僕は今この場で
脇汗た方が書きながら
最後にメッセージを言わせてください
僕もこの番組いる皆さんもそしておそらく
世界中の誰もがどんなに大変どんなに面倒
くさくてどんなに苦手なことに対しても
これはやる価値がある自分で思ったことは
きっと自ら進んで行動します
僕はそれが年齢の性別も国籍も
民族も思想の違いを乗り越えてsdgsの
17番目の目標
パートナーシップを達成していく
重要な会議になるんじゃないかこれまでの
取り組みを通じてそんなことを考えるよう
になりました
はい僕のお話が皆さんにとって何か新しい
気づきを
提供できたとしたらこれに勝る喜びはあり
ません以上で僕のスピーチを終わります
最後まで聞いてくださって本当に
ありがとうございました